your insurance agency is back to remind
you how important it is for your client
care
member care and patient care to align
what does that mean
take a look
[Music]
you need someone you can work with that
you can trust to help you navigate the
plan that's best for you
you need to have a health plan that's
going to be suitable to your personal
needs because every plan is uniquely
placed in the market
and then lastly is as i mentioned before
it's about trusting your doctor if you
don't have a trust with your primary
care doctor
you're not going to have a lot of
success with your health plan with your
health care needs
here at p3 our mission is all about
patient-centered care
so when it lines up right between the
healthcare and our mission
we have patients who have the insurance
that lets them go to the right pcp
that lets them get the medicines they
need that lets them see the specialists
they need
everything just lines up the way it's
supposed to be prepared
we need you to gather your doctors your
medications
to actually work with the broker to
actually make the right informed
decisions you can't go in
and not be prepared but also we've gone
through a vetting process with p3
the partner with the right brokers to
help you have
the best success if you will i love to
have my patients check in with me
to to ask questions about their
insurance i don't necessarily know all
the financial part of it but i know what
their medical needs are
and to help them understand what
questions to ask so that they're getting
their medical needs met with the right
insurance
one of the concerns you have to be
concerned about is we have timelines
everything has open aroma like when we
work we had open enrollment once a year
with our employer correct
with medicare we can start looking
effective october 1st with all the new
plan
choices coming it's now is the time to
start doing your investigation
now is the time to do your research and
get be prepared so you can make that
best decision and for example we have
plans that have
concierge doctors that are virtual
for those that are like the technology
want to take advantage of it
but also with some of the plans they
actually have where they're actually
giving
ipads and eye watches away as well
why so they can engage their doctor in a
different level and track their health
these options can be paid for through
their health plan they select so it's
just one of the many options and
features we can discuss
if you're interested in learning more
about what's available you can look us
up i know that you can pop into one of
the p3 clinics
and we have brokers at key locations
make sure you look for the broker that's
got the yia
your insurance agency or the carruthers
agency tag because those ones have been
vetted
to be good strong partners with p3
this information was brought to you by
alignment healthcare and your insurance
agency
for more information call 702 5500 or
visit
y i a ld.com